attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
mais la mecque une heure de retard
qu'est ce que t'as foutu
j'avais prévenu d'arrivée labour je vais
pas porter les trucs lourd voit déjà
merci d'être venu parce que je n'aurais
pas misé sur toi ça me fait chier mais
bon j'ai porté quelques cartons un comme
ça tu ne sera redevable
bon il ya déjà des gens pour t'aider à
nantes est le premier bailleur une cache
aux toilettes le temps quelqu'un d'autre
arrive les choix de ségou s'est passé
là-bas
super qu'est-ce qu'ils font ça va
arrêter ou la nef et moi mais n'ont pas
encore là a rappelé - concert fini et
puis moi je viendrai hockey dans
quelques mois qu'ils bossent ça nous
regarde
l'ancien locataire et c'est toutes ces
merdes non ça c'est à moi ça c'est moche
c'est dégueulasse t'as pas de vous tous
à ces cinq mois en fait je t'ai pas dit
mais tu es bienvenue à la crémaillère tu
verras j'ai fait un event facebook c'est
le 12 et je sais je suis dessus c'est
plus le doubs c'est le 14 juin de
changer ce coma le 12 une grosse soirée
ça m'arrange pas du tout 14 comme faible
[ __ ] c'est lourd je sais je me suis
mis en route comme ça c'est toi qui as
tout le poids c'est moi là-bas suivi
pour boire des bières apéro ça se passe
ça va tu as eu un problème sur la route
a pas du tout non non ça fait une heure
que là mais quand j'ai vu qu'il reste
plein de trucs à monter je me suis calé
au café d'en face
elles sont en vie nous non mais c'est le
déménagement c'est pas la crémaillère
est d'ailleurs la crémaillère c'est le
14 non finalement c'est le 15e mois le
quator j'ai plein de potes qui pouvaient
pas venir du coup à moi si ça mange au
slogan no 15 et 20 personnes blessées
[Musique]